recently I had a chance to visit the Ark
Encounter theme park with my friend and
colleague Krista Robins she flew down
from Chicago I came over from Oregon to
Kentucky to witness this spectacle both
Krista and I are science advocates were
highly involved in public education and
so there were certain parts of the Ark
Encounter that rubbed us the wrong way
as you might imagine but it was a
fascinating experience we even got to go
behind the scenes and meet some of the
people involved in the Ark Encounter
this is me with Nathaniel Jensen he's
actually a trained PhD biologist in this
the first of several videos on the Ark
Encounter that I'll be doing I'm going
to share with you my initial thoughts
and a few of the things that I saw dear
viewer so kick back relax and enjoy the
show
[Music]
[Music]
my name is John Perry I am a science
educator I actually create materials for
teachers to use in their classrooms I do
animations and I also write articles and
do other things my focus is on genetics
and evolution and so for a long time
I've been wanting to go to the Ark
Encounter because I've heard that they
are teaching some things about genetics
and evolution that aren't quite up to
par with the scientific standards so I
figured I go down there check it out and
report back to you the good people of
the internet quick note before I begin
and show you what I saw this issue is
actually fairly controversial and people
I've noticed I just did a video a few
weeks ago on creationism there's been a
lot of angry comments and people arguing
and fighting
please keep things civil in the comments
section if somebody insults you just
ignore it just ignore the insult and
respond to the actual question or the
actual point that they were trying to
make if you treat an angry person with
respect they will almost always mirror
your respect and you can actually take
what starts out as an angry fight and
turn it into a fruitful conversation
even on YouTube even in the comments
section I promise you so without further
ado let's take a look at the Ark
Encounter and see what it is that there
is to see touring the Ark was
fascinating the the project was
spearheaded by an evangelical preacher
named Ken Ham who has described the
project as a Christian themed amusement
park now in my opinion the park actually
serves four distinct purposes three of
which I suppose I'm okay with the first
one is that the Ark Encounter acts to
bring to life the biblical story of
Noah's Ark or I guess more specifically
it brings to life ken ham's version of
the Bible's story of Noah's Ark spoiler
alert ken ham's version of the story has
lots and lots and lots of dinosaurs in
it also the kin of dinosaurs things like
Dimetrodon and you know pterosaurs
he has a very fascinating interpretation
of the Bible to say the least the art on
display at the Ark was absolutely
stunning beautiful sculpture
of different animals different dinosaur
reconstructions I saw some people online
complaining that there wasn't enough
stuff to see in the Ark I can kind of
get that you know it's 40 bucks to get
in but that the paintings were beautiful
the sculptures were beautiful as an
artist my favorite part of the Ark
Encounter was this display that was in a
section about the sinful world before
the flood there's this giant he's like
two times the size of everybody else and
he's stabbing this lady with a spear
it's pretty brutal but then they were
fighting a dinosaur now I didn't see any
labels explaining what species of
dinosaur this was but it looks to me
like a Carnotaurus the horns on the head
and the flat muzzle give it away
Carnotaurus was a really really amazing
dinosaur unfortunately we only know of
it from one really good specimen found
in Cretaceous rocks in Argentina and
they had these beautiful horns on their
heads you can see the bones here we
assumed that there was actually probably
a lot of keratin structure on top of
these bones we don't know how long the
actual horns would have been in life but
this would have been an absolutely
spectacular creature to see in person
sadly the fossil record strongly
suggests that carnotaurs did not survive
the mass extinction that killed off most
of the dinosaurs
according to modern dating methods that
extinction occurred roughly 66 million
years ago
this means that scenarios like the one
depicted here well they wouldn't have
actually been able to happen but I love
it I just love it it's so imaginative
you've got people fighting these
blinged-out dinosaurs gladiator-style
so that's the first thing that the Ark
Encounter does it brings to life ken
ham's version of the Bible story of
Noah's Ark and and it does a good job at
that it really does the second main
purpose for the Ark Encounter is to act
as a place of worship ken ham's version
of Christianity the the things that he
teaches up at the Ark Encounter and then
and his other museum he has a museum
called the Creation Museum his version
of Christianity is extremely unique
particularly his interpretation of
Genesis I mean it's dinosaurs everywhere
there's dinosaurs in the Garden of Eden
there's t-rex on Noah's Ark I feel like
Ken hams interpretation of Christianity
is so unique that it almost needs its
own name
you know Hammond ISM after Ken Ham just
a little bit of trivia about myself I
was actually raised in the Mormon Church
I no longer participate but when I was
active in the church people had asked me
a lot of times you know what is
Mormonism and I would respond well do
you want the long serious answer or do
you want the short light-hearted answer
my kind of short answer was Mormonism is
Christianity meets cowboys and Indians
if I were to give a light-hearted
description of shamanism it would be
Hammond ISM is Christianity meets
Jurassic Park at the Ark Encounter the
thing that summarized what I'm calling
Hammond ISM better than probably
anything else was a little plaque that
reads did you know that up to 85 kinds
of dinosaurs were on the ark including
two tyrannosaurids - Stegosaurus - sarah
top seeds and - Brachiosaurus so yeah I
love that that's just that is a classic
example of Hammond ISM in case you
needed one I'm an American I care a lot
about freedom of speech I care a lot
about the right to assemble I care a lot
about separation of church and state I
care a lot about a freedom of religion
so I'm okay with the first two purposes
of the Ark Encounter just so long as
it's not funded by taxes or the
government and not promoted by the
public school system the third purpose
of the Ark Encounter by my account is to
preach Hammond ISM all throughout the
Ark there were all kinds of displays
that were designed to convert skeptics
whether they be outside of
she anity altogether you know
non-religious folks or whether they be
Christians that are not also Hema
Knights
Ken Ham is trying to convert people to
his way of thinking about Genesis let me
be clear he's not trying to like take
people from their religions and make
them get baptized into his own special
religion instead he's trying to get
people from various Christian
backgrounds to accept the special new
non biblical doctrines that he's
produced his unique additions to the
book of Genesis these include baby
t-rexes on Noah's Ark and extremely
rapid speciation or hyper evolution
after Noah's Flood he's doing work with
the Baptist Southern Baptist Convention
trying to make sure that they get on
board get on board no pun intended
the fourth purpose of the Ark Encounter
is one that did bother me I care deeply
about science education I care deeply
about scientific literacy of my fellow
citizens and the fourth purpose of the
Ark Encounter was to spread anti science
propaganda and conspiracy theories on
the third floor of the Ark Encounter are
where Ken Ham has most of his scientific
claims about animals and geology and the
age of the earth and so on in future
videos I'll show you that many of his
displays were either misleading or in
some cases blatantly incorrect and not
only that but a lot of them were
spreading conspiracy theories really
pitting the viewer against science in
general now that there are a lot of
Christians they don't have any issues
with science at all a lot of a lot of
people even the science of evolution
there are a lot of Christians that have
no problem with it there are some
Christians that have an issue with
evolution but they don't really have an
issue with other branches of science but
Ken Ham really seemed to be anti science
in general
he had particularly there was one part
let me read this to you this is from Ken
hams Mars exhibit and he talks about the
discovery that Mars seems to have once
had an ocean that covered part of its
surface in the distant past
we of course no longer find liquid water
on Mars one of his plaque says why do so
many scientists reject a massive flood
on earth while accepting one on Mars the
truth is that the world wide flood
described in Genesis would completely
undermine evolutionary beliefs about
life on this planet the rejection of the
Biblical Flood is often due to
evolutionary biases rather than the
actual evidence in fact it is not a
stretch to think that nearly every
geologist would appeal to a global flood
to explain many of Earth's features if
the Bible had never mentioned such an
event in this plaque he is making a huge
conspiracy theory claim he is saying
that scientists all around the world
from China to the Middle East to you
know Canada and the United States
everybody is teaming up to attack the
Bible scientists everywhere are teaming
up to attack the Bible first of all
that's completely not true there are
tons of
scientists that are Christians huge
numbers of scientists are Christians but
that is just a horrible horrible thing
to be claiming he's teaching these
people that scientists are against them
this is a really a really really
destructive thing to be teaching
children oh the children you know is a
destructive thing to be teaching anybody
it was it was very shocking
in a future video I'll be going over
some of the details of ken ham's Mars
exhibit and we'll see just exactly how
accurate it is but for now just ask
yourself this one question what's more
likely that thousands of independent
researchers have teamed up against Ken
hams interpretation of the Bible or that
Ken Ham may have just misinterpreted
some of the data which of these two
options seems most likely to you perhaps
there's a third or a fourth or a fifth
option that I've overlooked here let me
know your thoughts in the comment
section so I'm going to be doing a
series of videos make sure to subscribe
to my youtube channel and click the
little bell icon so that you get
notified when I publish those videos I
got me doing a whole series where I go
through one by one these different
claims that Ken Ham makes at the Ark
Encounter and I'm going to show you what
the actual science tells us so that's
gonna be a lot of fun I look forward to
seeing fruitful friendly conversations
in the comment section just to sum
things up before I sign off here today
we have learned a new word feminism the
version of Christianity that Ken Ham has
recently put together throughout his
career and we went over what I saw to be
the four purposes of the Ark Encounter
the last one really kind of yeah rose me
the wrong way
so yes subscribe to my youtube channel
if you want to see more hit the little
notification bell to make sure that you
get a notification next time I produce a
video in this series so long for now
stay curious
you